in the next 10 minutes i'm going to show
you exactly how you can create this
house design without knowing anything
about archicad at all okay so today
we're going to be starting with a
standard arcade 25 template i'm using my
own custom template that i'm developing
for you guys so it is very bare bones at
the moment you can use whatever template
is available to you it'll be very much
the same process so if we start with
archive25 open ready to go we usually
start with the very blank canvas itself
on the left hand side here we're going
to have all of our toolbars and all of
our options that we require to be able
to create what we are trying to do today
so what we're going to be doing today is
creating a very simple a-frame house
design so if we use our view map or even
our project map we can come across to
our ground floor double click and make
sure we're on the correct floor that we
need to be working on next we're going
to select our slab tool we're going to
click once we're going to show our layer
and then we're going to change it to the
basic rectangular method of drawing a
slab now simply dragging out that slab
without clicking and holding is going to
give you all sorts of dimensions
i personally want to make this about 10
meters wide so i'm going to type in 10
000 press the tab button and i want to
make it 20 meters long so i'm going to
type in 20 000. now if i wanted to move
this slab all i'd have to do is select
the slab press control or command d for
david to be able to move it around next
i'm going to click on this slab go
command t for tomic and then change the
actual ground floor layer or the home
story i want that to be on the footings
layer or whatever you have designated in
your story settings to basically drop it
one level down now because it is
calculated from the bottom of the seal
to the top of the actual floor i want to
increase that by 250 millimeters and
press ok what you'll see is that slab
has completely disappeared on us right
click on the footings layer and go show
as trace reference so then we'll see
our actual slab that we drew a second
ago
in this trace reference section now to
create our a-frame we want to come to
our wall tool we want to select our
outside face and then select some sort
of wall structure that we're going to be
using to construct this and draw all the
way up clicking once
repeating that same step again on the
other side now what you'll see is
basically two very very basic walls with
nothing interesting going on so if we
come to our marquee tool let's marquee
everything we've drawn so far right
click so show marquee in 3d window and
all of a sudden we have a 3d window two
walls and a basic slab now what we want
to do is select one of our walls on the
left hand or the right hand side click
command t again for katomich so now we
want to angle our wall over across to
the right hand side or closer to that
a-frame so if we click on this angled
wall section traditionally 90 degrees
45-135 so if we go 135 as a starting
base we're going to see that is quickly
changed to a a-frame style repeat the
same process on the opposite wall give
this 135 on that opposite wall as well
now what we need to do is actually
extend the length of our wall to a
certain point so if we select both these
walls command t again we do not link any
of our top stories and let's just change
that to five meters for now the reason i
initially went with five meters is
because my slab is ten meters long which
means five meters five meters but what i
didn't account for is the thickness of
the actual walls themselves now with in
this instance we have a five meter high
overall a-frame which is basically going
to only be enough for one single story
if we wanted to make this larger or
taller in any single way we would simply
just adjust the angle of these walls to
be able to increase the pitch and
therefore give us more height in the
upper floor
personally i do think we need more
height so i'm going to change both of
these up to about 120 degrees and there
we go now i've increased both of these
wall heights to 8.44 meters at 120
degrees which by tapping the m button
opens my measuring tool it indicates to
me that i have 8.44 meters in the center
of that ridge to basically use as grand
space coming back into my floor plan i'm
then going to click the escape button
hold the option or the alt button
depending on what system you're on and
draw the two external walls what you'll
find is those external walls are also
pivoting and we don't want to do that so
command t let's just simply make them
straight walls and they have to be new
construction if you're using renovation
layers i'll duplicate that same process
on the opposite side and then come back
into my 3d layer so now what you see in
3d is an automatically cropped external
wall aligning with our other walls that
are basically defining our roof
structure coming back to our ground
floor plan we want to basically create
an alfresco or a cove some sort of
entryway at the front of our building so
i'm going to call this the front for the
simple purposes of argument press click
once on this external wall control
command d click on an external edge hold
shift and then i'm going to move that
two and a half meters back
what that's going to create is that
alcove i'm looking for and then i'm
simply going to change the materials of
the external walls so by selecting all
of the external walls and holding shift
and holding down the mouse wheel i can
move around
press command t to open up the settings
and then i can change the actual
external color and material of these
walls for the purpose of this i'm simply
going to go with a color bond basalt or
a dark gray color press ok
and then i'm going to change the other
materials that i need to look a little
bit nicer so these two walls as an
external feature you're going to see the
inside of that lining the cladding so
then i'm going to change that to a nice
timber if you are in the architecture
industry a student or anything of the
sorts make sure you check out
davidtomich.com.u down below for all of
your architectural requirements one of
the best items on the website is a
construction checklist it is the
fundamental basic guide that you need to
know and understand if you're producing
any sort of architectural documentation
so now we have a a-frame house with a
very basic understanding of walls slabs
next we want to talk about our doors and
our windows so then if we come up to our
door tool we can go to our door settings
at the top and select a number of
variety of different doors you can
scroll through use any one of these
doors that you see fit for your project
but for the purposes of argument i'm
simply just going to use the basic door
25
and i'm going to drop it roughly in the
middle of this project here what you can
see is it's a very very small door
compared to the rest of the project
because it is a very grand a-frame house
coming back to our floor plan you're
going to see that door automatically
inputted into our program so you don't
have to go and double up regardless of
where you make the change which is one
of the best advantages of 3d software
now i'm going to simply come into my
window tool and repeat that exact same
process selecting some sort of window
from the standard windows available in
archicad 25 let's select that one and
introduce it both sides of our door now
what you see is those windows they're
not the right place for me they're not
the right color there's a number of
things wrong with them so if we select
both of our windows at once command t
opens up our settings now if we click on
this elevation tool at the top the front
we're going to be able to see what our
window looks like from an elevation next
we're just going to change both of those
to a fixed glaze window for the purposes
of argument come down to model
attributes and we're going to change
our actual framing materials if we
wanted to so for now i'm just going to
change them to a nice dark black color
pressing ok changes all of those
materials like we said before and then i
can simply select on one of these
windows and adjust it closer to my door
adjust the height in the same manner by
selecting the up and down tool and then
i can also adjust the actual overall
height of that window by simply
selecting the adjustment tools available
when you click on one of the nodes last
but not least i want to adjust this door
i'm going to open up those settings
let's go to a hv grid and simply change
the door frame to a nice black as well
pressing ok
we have the very beginning of our
a-frame house designed and completed if
we then wanted to introduce an
additional floor into this project we
could select our ground ceiling go to
our slab tool replicate the slab below
now what we find is our slab tool is
sticking out completely too far so we're
going to select our slab click on this
blue line go to our perimeter or offset
edge adjustment tool and simply drag
that to the inside of our walls where we
need it to actually be now if we click
on our little running man down the very
bottom left hand corner explore you're
going to get the basic 3d controls i
don't really need to see that again so
let's explore in 3d
fly inside our house and we're going to
be able to see we've created that floor
we've got a second floor
and we can continue to basically develop
this exact same concept we just talked
about with the windows and the doors on
the first floor now what i've simply
gone ahead and done is selected a
triangle window instead of the basic
windows that we used down here below and
extended these two windows to match our
triangle window above if i wanted to
replicate this wall on the back side
without having to do all of that again i
could count back down to our ground
floor select this wall command d press
the option or alt button control m to
mirror click click
delete our external wall and then
reposition our wall at the very end last
but not least i would again drag that in
2.5 meters to make it symmetrical select
the slab bring it
halfway into our property so it's only a
mezzanine floor rather than an entire
floor and then that way if we were to
fly back into our house once more we'd
basically see a very simple mezzanine
concept on the back side a grand entry
space on the front side and we can
simply just create a set of stairs a
balustrade and introduce some furniture
whenever we're ready and that's all from
me my name is david thomich and i'll see
you next monday